hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast whole-genome the future of
high-quality genomes and trench
transcriptomes I am Judy Oracle a brutes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's webcast is presented by
lab routes comm reading social media
site for science professionals before we
start there are a few instructions this
is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over and to get
your credits click on the cee button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answer is welcome to you can do
this by hitting the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can want a better look you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the top right or use the Q&A
button we'll make sure we try to resolve
any issues now let's get right to
today's presenter we are proud to
welcome yonas core lock PhD chief
scientific officer for Pacific
Biosciences dr. Carlock co-invented
smart technology with Stephen Turner p
HD pacific biosciences founder and chief
technology officer when the two were
graduate students at Cornell University
dr. Carlock joined Pacific Biosciences
in 2004 as the company's eight employee
he is the recipient of multiple grants
and inventor on point 162 issued us
patents in an author of numerous
scientific studies on the principles and
applications of smart technology
including a publications in nature
science and pnas dr. Carlock received
both his PhD in his MS degrees in
biochemistry molecular and cell biology
from cornell and ms and BA
in biological sciences from Humboldt
University in berlin germany I'm now
turning over to dr. Carlock for his
presentation thank you very much Judy
and also warm welcome for me as well to
today's seminar I'm holding on the
future of high-quality genomes and
transcriptomes during which I'd like to
give you some updates and some examples
of the latest research from the
scientific community applying peg
biotechnology and PI file sequencing for
higher quality genomes and
transcriptomes and the title whole
genome ? i get an was inspired by a
editorial perspective few months ago in
nature genetics which had the same title
where the journal editors wrote that it
is time in their opinion it is time to
stop thinking that merely more DNA
sequencing by that they meant short
reach DNA sequencing will give us the
variance determine human traits and they
noted that our genomes come in many
flavors of combinations of rare and
common variation on many different
spatial scales not just single
nucleotide changes but also larger
structure variation and we know since
2007 this was the great winter genome
paper that nan sniff DNA variation is
very important and very abundant in fact
the authors in this paper noted that
even though nan snip DNA variation only
accounts for about a fifth of all the
events that were identified in the donor
and craig Venter they involve
seventy-four percent of all variant
basis that means three quarters of all
the bases that are different between you
and me are not in sniffs not in single
based changes and they suggested an
important role for this non sniff
genetic alteration in defining the
diploid genome structure so what do we
mean by non snip on DNA variation here
up here is a graph showing the various
kinds of so-called structural variation
that's larger variation where you have
the lesions on larger regions of the
gene
deleted in the individual compared to
the reference genome tandem duplications
variable number tendon repeats disperse
duplications novel insertions that only
this individual has but are not in the
reference repeat insertions inversions
where the orientation is flipped or
transmutations and if the importance of
this type of variation starts with
genetic variation has been highlighted
this is just one example from a review
paper by Richard gifts and jean-luc ski
from Baylor noting that over a third of
these gene of all the genes in the human
genome are encompassed either totally or
partially by a copy number variation
another term for structural variation
that can alter the expression or even
that structure possibly giving rise to
novel fusion transcripts and they note
that detection of structural variation
is imperative in any whole genome
sequencing study but of course that's
typically not being done with the short
route systems and the limitations of
alumina sequencing other short read
technologies has been highlighted in the
number of papers just one example from
Stephen share in Toronto where they
compare the different technologies
four-by-four alumina solid Complete
Genomics against the human genome
reference and found that the current
high throughput short lead sequencing
approaches only detected a fraction of
the full-sized spectrum of insertions
deletions and copy number variants
compared to the reference and they
posited that generating longer reads can
mitigate these shortcomings so as you
know smart sequencing has different
characteristics from aluminum even
Sanger sequencing and I've listed here
the four performance areas that you want
to consider really when evaluating any
sequencing technology and so you know
that with the very long reads the
average are no over 10,000 bases a high
consensus accuracy of greater than
99.999% of QB 50 or less than 1 error in
100,000 basis at 30 fold sequencing
depth the lack of bias with respect to
GC percentage or low
exedy sequence and the unique ability to
detect DNA modifications and
characterize the epigenome as part of
the sequencing process with this
performance with these performance
metrics it has now been possible to
characterize regions and resolve genomes
at a much more complete and
comprehensive level and so I want to
give a couple examples of this in the
following the first example that I want
to highlight is in the area of type of a
class of diseases called repeat
expansion diseases and there are many of
them this is a review article from 2007
highlighting that these the expansion of
the shorts tri tetra or more complex
sequence motifs can lead to many
different diseases on such as
Huntington's disease ALS spinocerebellar
ataxia and so forth and so as just one
example this was a study that was
published in 2014 by a group of japanese
researchers looking at spinocerebellar
ataxia type 31 now in the human genome
reference you see up here on the top
there is a region on chromosome 16 that
has 11 units of this particular Penta
nucleotide motif taaa a in an individual
that's been that has the SCA 31 disease
that's not what you find instead you
find this massive expansion and very
complex pattern of these of all of these
different repeats which I've color coded
in the schematic in the middle and then
have listed them on the right moreover
so you know this is not part of the
reference moreover if you then look at
the next individual you see a very
similar but slightly different pattern
so if I move back and forth you can see
that here in the middle it this
particular section right here is shifted
so the number of these repeat units are
different and so in the paper it was
highlighted that these are highly
structurally dynamic structurally
unstable region
in the human genome and that you really
need long reads not sequencing to
resolve these so this figure from the
paper is 11 patients that were looked at
with smart sequencing the canonical
sequence on the bottom was determined
and then the bars in the graph represent
the length of these particular repeat
units of the KL m and n and you can see
that for each of those patients they're
all different highlighting the high
structural diversity and variation in
these repeats the paper also pointed out
that these there are many regions in the
genome that are longer than what you can
find in the reference genome so in the
figure here on the bottom you see that
it might be possible to resolve some of
these in the reference but then
precisely for the individuals where
you're trying to make a diagnosis that
have the disease you run into the
limitations of the short lead sequencing
technology so probably around this area
right here is where the limit for the
short reach sequencers are located
that's about 200 250 basis so ease some
of these repeats stretch out to 600
internal basis and you really need an
unbiased laundry technology that can go
through these types of repeats to
resolve them and this is not an isolated
example I just want to mention one other
paper looking at another type of this
spinocerebellar ataxia type 10 and a
very similar picture emerges here the
figure on the right for patients ABCD
you see this very large heterogeneity
and diversity in the structural
composition of the disease implicated
repeats the second example that I want
to highlight for resolving structural
variation and complex regions in the
genome in a targeted fashion is in the
area of pharmacogenomics cytochrome p450
2d6 or 6 26 as i call it is a very
important gene it's directly involved in
the Macau
about a quarter of all the commonly used
drugs into clinical target for a drug
metabolism efficiency and it's difficult
to study because it's a highly
polymorphic gene there are over a
hundred variants including a full gene
duplication and deletion events and so
most genotypic am typing assays because
of this complexity only interrogate a
small subset of the variants and they
default to the diplo type standard call
in case this information is missing in
the panel so just to highlight the
important so different people have
different genotypes and that directly
affects their phenotype on how quickly
and how efficiently they can metabolize
these drugs so in order to do this
research and ultimately have a better
understanding of how much of the drug
should a particular patient receive
either doing clinical trial or then
ultimately in the future for patient
management it's very important to know
this genotype phenotype direction and so
on Scott Stewart at Mount Sinai has
published a paper and presented this
work highlighting that it's complicated
by the fact that there is a a copy on
there's a neighboring pseudogene which
has 97% homology right next to the sub
26 genie and in the paper he published a
little while ago Stuart Scott entitled
long lead single molecule come full gene
sequencing of sub 26 he pointed out that
short read sequencing is not an
effective approach force of 26 full gene
characterization and that long reach sib
26 smart sequencing is an innovative
reproducible and validated method for
characterizing or full gene identifying
the duplications and discovering novel
yields which will likely improve thus if
26 metabolize a phenotype prediction for
both research and clinical testing
applications just a couple examples he
initially are validated the method by
looking at 10 previously characterized
DNA
people say a perfect importance with the
previous genotype calls and in fact one
of the samples showed the duplication
events that had been missed by the other
platform and Latino types were refined
in some cases so here you see that there
was refinement of the genotype from the
previous luminex or tech man copy number
essays this is the duplicate from smart
sequencing there was a duplication
allele that was characterized that was
missed before and there were a number of
novel only of super characterized and
then he looked at fourteen samples with
discrepant results from the multiple
genotyping in the luminex and attackman
and were able to resolve this fully with
subtly resolution refining the genotype
characterizing duplications and in some
cases finding completely novel kendama
rearrangements that were not found
before so then to address the question
of well how much structure variation is
there in the human genome this was a
paper from last year looking at and
trying to address this question of an
IKE Lauren colleagues looked at a
particular human DNA sample and applied
smart sequencing and so in this study
they resolved over 26,000 of these types
of structure variants at the beta fair
level and remarkably eighty-five percent
of these about 22,000 were completely
novel highlighting that we've really had
a blind spot in the area of genomics not
being able to resolve and understand and
capture those particular types of
genetic variation almost 7000 of these
were in inside jeans and the validation
rate is really high so in my paper you
can see this figure that it's fans this
type of variation spends all the way
from 50 bases all the way to 20,000
bases and all the data that you see in
black and red were all new discoveries
and in grey and pink were previously
reported structure variants and some
particular classes are particularly
poorly represented through the short
week sequencing technology so here's an
example where less than one percent of
insertions are
present in the new assembly that were
derived from Premier League Illumina
sequencing so here is complex insertions
short tandem repeats and variable number
can repeats the peg bio work identified
about a thousand seven hundred events
adding about 3.5 mega bases of sequence
and the same sample sequence with
alumina only identified 14 out of those
thousand seven hundred and you can see
that they're also very poorly
represented in the reference the latest
reference only has five of these events
capturing this particular type of
variation so to summarize this is a very
famous graph of course on that I'm sure
you've all have seen where that talks
about the decrease in the cost of
sequencing but what I want to highlight
is there's a dilemma of the quantity
versus the quality of the information
that we're getting yes sequencing has
gotten very cheap however the ability to
comprehensively characterize the genome
and to assemble human genomes de novo
certainly has not followed that same
trend and in fact according to the NHGRI
site the very definition of what it
means to sequence a genome was actually
changed in 2008 from an assembly of view
point to a remapping the point and so I
just want to play a perspective that
David Haussler from the University of
California and Santa Cruz gave on on
this particular issue
so then I want to now talk about de novo
assembly and this was nicely highlighted
the need for being able to put together
human genome from scratch was
highlighted nicely in this review
article genetic variation and renewable
assembly of human genomes by marc jayson
rick wilson devon eichler what they
pointed out that the short read
massively parallel sequencing is
insufficient to generate high-quality
genome assemblies or result more
structure variation and they emphasize
the importance of complete de novo
assembly as opposed to read mapping as
the primary means to understanding the
full range of human genetic variation so
there has been a transformation through
the introduction of this Mon sequencing
technology in our ability to put
together human genomes from scratch on
to higher quality in this graph I show a
timeline you see on the on the left here
on the year when these studies were
carried out and this goes from 2007 all
the way to last year looking at the
different technologies with different
assemblers and then the graph on the
right shows one metric of the quality of
a human assembly which is continent 50
that's a metric of the contiguity and
you can see that over the last seven
years between 2007 and 2014 really the
community hasn't made much progress on
being able to generate high-quality than
almost endless and with the emergence of
protect our students mark sequencing and
the Falcon assembler it's not possible
to generate very high quality human
genome assemblies that have content and
fifties in the mega bass range what that
means in practice is shown is shown here
where the latest assembly of chm one
just joined two chromosomes we're in
blue you can see individual context that
are greater than five mega bases and so
some of these contexts spend entire
chromosome arms in an uninterruptible
can text not scaffolds so they only
contain AG CS and T's and no n basis no
gaps and completely resolving this
this has been described in other papers
this was a paper by an Philippian and
colleagues developing efficient assembly
algorithms to give rise to these higher
quality genomes and on the figure on the
right you see a comparison on the left
of each chromosome arms detect by
assembly and on the right of each
chromosome arm is the corresponding
shortly assembly and then in terms of
the ability to see the genome
comprehensively this is a study by left
by researchers at Mount Sinai a de novo
assembly of the human genome and on the
bottom here you see again the ability to
see lots of structure variance with the
tech file and then in contrast with the
alumina technology is when we see a very
small fraction of this type of variation
and this paper also pointed out that
certain types of radiation are
systematically underestimated in the
human reference genome so this figure is
particularly about short tandem repeats
where compared to the reference you have
a an over-representation of data points
indicating that these are much longer
than they're actually present in the
reference genome so I want to give one
example of what what it means to have a
higher quality reference and what I'd
like to focus on is the immunoglobulin
heavy chain locus the IgH locus which of
course is extremely important because
it's responsible for antibody heavy
chain biosynthesis it's vital for the
adaptive immune response so it's it's
naturally crucial for understanding many
diseases and in addition to the
reference effort of the human genome
reference in 2013 a paper was published
by Rick Wilson a vernacular and others
with a very laborious and time and labor
intensive approach to resolve a second
individual this was a hydrogen to form
old to get a second haplotype
representation of this particular locus
using a back based approach and using
Sanger sequencing and as you can see
here in the figure on the top you can
appreciate why it's so difficult to
resolve these particular regions that
include the vga
regions that make other than the
antibodies because they are highly
repetitive and very complex having a
high quality de novo assembled genome
with pacbio can give you these regions
automatically just straight out of the
assembly so for two hydrogen for moles
ehm one that's the same one that was
used in 2013 and then another one CH n
13 if you look at the assembly and ask
where the IgH locus is they are fully
resolved in single large context in the
pycnogenol assemblies in chm one that
region lies in a contact of 6.6 mega
bases in chm 13 and a content of 1.7
million reasons and so you can then
immediately asked about the differences
and so the bioinformaticians don't have
to spend all their time trying to put
things together but they can actually
now go to what they wanted to do in the
first place which is to analyze and
annotate those particular regions
functionally and so for chm 39 show by
example this is a dot plot which gives
you a high-level comparison between the
sample of interests of that particular
legion and the reference sequences on
the y-axis so this is a large region
about 1.4 megabases depicted here and
when you have a diagonal line that means
the sequences are important when you
have breaks in these lines that means
they're structural differences so it's a
little bit hard to see in the screen but
there's a discontinuity here and because
it's a large scale so i zoom into this
particular region here is a short tandem
repeat expansion where you have 2350
base pairs in the chm one sample vs 50
bases in the reference here's another
example 2.6 k be of short tandem repeats
compared to 760 bases in the reference
there is a 19.5 kilobase 10 and repeat
expansion in this igh locus in chm 14
compared to the reference there is an
inversion of about five kilo bases on
which you can identify in the dolphin
looks like this there was an 8.5
kilodays insertion at this locus another
25 cutie 10 and repeat expansion here
and another shortcut American expansion
there so you see that there are quite a
number of structural differences large
structural changes between the
particular sample that was sequenced and
automatically gave a complete picture of
the IgH locus compared to the reference
and then we can compare both of the
sample chn 1ch on 13 and you can see
that some of the variation is the same
between the two so for example risk
short tandem repeat expansion the
inversion is the same this particular
insertion and so forth and some are
unique so for example here in chm 13 we
had the 25 kb 10 and repeat expansion
which is missing in and this is
comporting with the reference so it
gives you an immediate view now how did
the short lead assembly compared to this
work there was an aluminum-based not a
de novo assembly but a reference guided
assembly done before the pipeline award
which also by the way included a large
number of facts the content and 50 as I
mentioned before is only about a hundred
forty kilobases and in this assembly the
IgH locus is broken into three pieces in
a scaffold and it has two very large
gaps one is one kilobase and the other
is fifty thousand bases 50 kilo bases
and the IgH locus is not correctly
resolved so anywhere you go in this
particular region you have the letter
ends instead of actual a GCT basis and
when when you then you can ask for how
to protect by awesome resolve those
particular regions the first gap was
filled with 2.8 kilobase of actual real
sequence and the second gap was filled
it's not fifty thousand bases in length
but it's actually 135,000 bases in
length so even these estimate of the
size of the gap was incorrect in the
short read assembly so to summarize
there's a as a substantial difference
between when you talk about context and
scout
holds context are continuous pieces of
sequence information that contains only
ACG sorties and that is what peck
biotechnology provides whereas scaffolds
some researchers have called them Swiss
cheese genomes have lots of holes with a
varying number and size of these gaps of
n basis those are holes in the genome
which translate to missing information
and caps of knowledge and one of the in
read length is not enough so you need
read lengths to span the repeats and to
resolve those into the context the other
aspect is the lack of GC bias and this
was also nicely highlighted in the paper
the difference between the two different
technologies where you have the Illumina
sequencing it's well known that at low
GC content so down here this is 18 rich
DNA and then hi GC DNA there are there's
bias and there's much less coverage and
lower quality sequence information
whereas with the peg biotechnology which
is shown you in green you have a very
even coverage and quality regardless of
the DNA that you're trying to sequence
and that is a fundamental prerequisite
of being able to on characterized
genomes comprehensively the last thing I
want to note about human genome
reference assemblies and the normal
assemblies is the importance in the
process of what we're seeing now of the
generation of ethnic background
sequences ethnic specific the neural
assemblies and human genome references
with the use of Peck biotechnology and
that is important because the ethnic
background critically matters to disease
risk disease association I just want to
highlight two examples this first one is
for the disease rheumatoid arthritis
these Korean researchers looked at a set
of snips that were associated in a
Caucasian population to contribute
significantly to disease in
for rheumatoid arthritis and they asked
a simple question of how many of these
snips play a role in contributing in to
the disease in the Korean population and
the answer was zero so none of the snips
that were identified in the Caucasian
cohort and any meaningful contribution
to the Korean population this of course
is also important in cancer this is a
very nice review paper looking at the
role of ethnic background and genetic
variation in the evaluation of cancer
risk and the authors here surveyed a
number of studies and found that a
significant result in one ethnic group
was usually not reproducible in other
ethnicities and well powered studies so
that is the reason why now the community
has engaged in generating high quality
reference genome assemblies with PEG
biotechnology here's a table of the
publicly announced on projects and so
you can see that there is quite a wide
variety of Asian European African
genomes that will give us that are
projected to give us a much better match
of the genomic data that you get from
population studies to the particular
reference that matches much better the
ethnicity of the cohort of the last
example of a recent pic biol genome
assembly that I would like to mention is
the gorilla genome this was featured on
the cover of science last month and it
provided a dramatic improvement over the
previous guerrilla assembly of course
the gorilla is not only important for
conservation efforts but also is our
closest relative final genetically and
so for areas like understanding speech
neurological conditions many diseases it
is info comparative genomics is very
useful to have a high quality gorilla
gentleman so in this particular pacbio
assembly you can see that there was a
dramatic improvement in
continuity over 150 fold many of the
gaps over ninety three percent of the
gaps in the previous assembly which was
in scaffolds not in context were closed
it added 150 mega bases of new sequence
corrected errors similarly about eighty
six percent of the structure grains are
completely new and it had corrections to
our previous estimates in terms of
evolution the paper had some really nice
figures that I think highlight the
difference between epic bio assembly on
the left so this was from the new work
compared to the previous short route
assembly with regard to what you're
looking at as scientists when you look
at longleat versus short lead assemblies
this is a figure of the in the paper
showing a histogram of this information
of the concrete length you can see in
black and blue the previous illuminance
sanger sequencing context and then in
red take bio sequencing context and this
is a log scale and so you can see that
the distributions are completely
separate and there was a thousand fold
on difference and improvement in will
protect biotechnology so um Evan eichler
the senior author of this paper was was
interviewed for a blog post accompanying
his paper and you know he had some I
thought really nice statement so I
apologize it's going to be a little bit
of text but I couldn't I couldn't really
say it any better than he did and so he
noted that the short read assemblies can
be like Swiss cheese with lots of
missing biological information in the
gaps the gaps are not random and are
clustered at sites of repeats and the
geneticists can capture these repeats
and determine the structural differences
they have problems understanding the
organization of genes and comparing
genetic variation within and across
species and he noted that fruit bar
sequencing the technology and the
computational biology have now advanced
to the stage where individual
laboratories can generate high-quality
genomes of mammals and this capability
has the promise to revolutionize our
understanding of genome evolution and
species biology he also pointed out that
he thought the take home message from
this study was that the new genome
technologies and assemblies bring
back to the place where we should have
been ten years ago so coming back to
that graph and the comment that David
Haussler made with regard to quantity
versus quality he said that he thinks
that if we depend only on target
sequences there's a [ __ ] in the armor
the work on the Berlin other human
genomes community demonstrate that large
swathes of genetic variation can't be
understood with the short lead
sequencing approaches and long reach
sequencing is allowing us to access a
new levels of genetic variation that
were previously inaccessible and he
concluded that given further advances of
the technology and I'll talk about the
sequel system at the end of the
presentation I'm willing to bet that
this is the way with all sequence human
genomes to discover disease-causing
mutations in the future so beyond the
human and our closest relatives there is
quite a number of projects that are now
underway and have already been published
on applying pacbio sequencing to get
much higher quality genomes of plants
animals bacteria and basically all parts
of the tree of life this is not meant to
be a phylogenetically accurate tree of
course it's just a illustration that
this is not happening and these are all
the genomes that we know of that have a
contact in fifty of greater than one
mega base and there's a hash tag with
the club if you have one you can you can
also participate so then in the last
sort of 10-15 minutes I want to now
switch to the transcriptome of course on
both all the genome transcriptome and
also the epigenome we won't have time to
talk about the epigenome today but the
transcriptome of course is just as
important in understanding biology
understanding disease and the molecular
mechanisms in addition to the genome
because it's up to the gene products and
the regulation to that are the
underlying of foundations of many of
diseases and so it's been recognized of
course that a particular gene can have
many different gene products and for
example in the human genome it is
estimated that over ninety-five percent
of all human genes are now alternatively
sliced meaning they have more than one
isoform more than one form of what the
gene can represent and of course is done
through alternate splicing of the
introns and and so forth and it's been
well recognized in the community that
the short lead sequencing technologies
have difficulties resolving this
architecture this complexity and if you
are limited to the reads that just
happen to span the splice junctions
there is insufficient connectivity and
so that leads to the splice ison from
uncertainty we and others have developed
solution that we call isoform sequencing
or ISO seek for short where the cDNA
libraries that are being made encompass
full length on cdna so the entire mRNA
molecule is converted into a
corresponding see DNA molecule and then
with the long reads that is sequence
with full resolution and with full
contiguity so that means there's no
assembly required at the end and you get
the isoforms out automatically out of
the sequencing process there are many
publications that have now appeared I've
listed a few of them here and I
understand we're making available the
presentations PDF so you can look this
up there's also a library resource on
our website where you can get to these
papers so I want to just highlight a few
so we talked about the IgH locus earlier
and there are a number of papers that
highlight that now on the mRNA level
when you make those heavy and light
chain RNA molecules that then make the
antibodies of course it is now very easy
to read through and directly resolve the
bdg a recombination events and
characterize the immune repertoire
either in an animal's these are two
studies that are on animals on the right
here you see in the figure on
lower right here you see from
researchers at the USDA Tim Smith
looking at the bow line I geg repertoire
forces is very important for disease
susceptibility of calves during
transport for example and you can
already visually appreciate that through
this characterization there's some very
different constitutions in the immune
repertoire in some of these different
animals the ability to read mRNA
molecules full-length is very useful for
characterizing fusion genes and of
course they're particularly important
cancer here's just one example of a
number of papers that have appeared now
this is in prostate cancer novel fusion
transcript between the human relax and
one in the human reluctant to gene this
paper I think is a nice example because
the authors highlight that they
basically threw the kitchen sink of
sequencing technologies added and
couldn't identify this fusion until they
use Peck pyrosequencing which very
confidently identified that there is
indeed a fusion between those two genes
which have a high homology and so it's
it's quite difficult with chaudhary
technologies to resolve this and in
terms of the functional significance on
just one example so they identified that
one of the fusion encodes an isoform
that does not then have the signal
peptide and so without the signal
peptide that normally would dictate the
transport through the Golgi apparatus
and and determine the best in destiny of
that particular protein inside the cell
this particular fusion protein will end
up in a completely different cellular
compartment because it lacks the signal
peptide so having this full contiguous
information really then helps you go
directly to the next level of
understanding and functionally and just
one other example in the area of cancer
looking at alternative splicing this is
from a presentation that was given at
the American Association of cancer
research in New Orleans last month by
researchers from the Netherlands Cancer
Institute they are interested in
looking for novel biomarkers for
colorectal cancer and it turns out that
as you go through the progressions in
colorectal cancer from the adenoma to
the carcinoma and there are changes in
the RNA splicing in many genes in the
tumor and so looking at differently
sliced isoforms can give you an
understanding where the cancer is at and
could complement or I'll perform the
current screening to give information
about these particular cancers so a
couple of examples looking at two
samples the green sample is the control
sample this is a cell line and then in
purple is a cell line where the
aberration or the changes in this by
singh machinery have been mimicked
through SNR SI rna-mediated
down-regulation of components of the
splicing machinery and so you can see
that through I so seek and the
collection of full-length mrna isoforms
it's very easy to see the changes these
are data that we're done on the sequence
system and so you see that for this
particular gene there's only one isoform
in the control and then there are three
gene products in the cell line that has
the modulation of the splicing machinery
and you can see which particular exons
are being nice now here's another
example and this is a gene that when we
found this in communicated this to the
collaborators they said oh that's one of
the genes that we really that's in our
top five list so they asked me to lock
out the identity of the gene because
there that's Gina's very important to
them but you can see that compared to
the control they are now changes and
excellent splicing again and you can
immediately identify which of the
isoforms have the exons that are spliced
out and which are still in the normal
state so lastly looking at the
transcriptome and how much do we know
already about the transcriptome versus
how much is there still to be learned
there was a paper into
the team one of the first I so sick
papers looking at what is arguably the
best studied transcriptome in the world
that's human embryonic stem cells so
literally billions of reads have been
billions of alumina reads have been
spent on that sample and in this paper
of the authors applied PacBio sequencing
and found that over one third of the
reads that came off the machine were new
either new isoforms or even new genes so
they identified 273 genes and concluded
that even in these well characterized
human cell lines and tissues the me a
process of identifying all the genes is
likely far to complete and they have
since gone on and interrogated these
discoveries further and found that some
of those new jeans were crucial for
regulating pluripotency during human
pre-implantation development and nuclear
reprogramming so during a development so
the ability of pec by sequencing to make
these discoveries then immediately led
to the identification of these crucial
regulators and this was very nicely
highlighted in a technology feature in
nature a few months ago that I recommend
if anyone is interested entitled finding
function and mystery transcripts so
these were directly enabled by peckville
sequencing data discoveries new
transcripts also help you make better
sense of the shorter e data so coming
back to the pnas paper they showed that
there is a much better quantification
with the inclusion of the new
transcripts you basically have a better
transcript of reference which then
allows you to make much more accurate
calls of the short read data for gene
expression for annotation and then this
was a I think an exciting first paper in
going to the next level of looking at
what we would call personal
transcriptomes so of course you all have
two coffees except for the male sex
chromosomes everyone has two copies of
the same gene and those can be
differentially expressed and in some
cases differentially slice and so Mike
Snyder
and co-workers in this pnas paper
utilized full-length icc profile
sequencing to differentiate the
transcripts from the different alleles
so in this figure here you see that for
this particular gene they were able to
cluster all the transcripts that came
from the first allele using snip
differences that are shown here by the
orange lines here and there that allows
you to cluster and identify which allele
whether that particular RNA came from
the mother chromosome or from the father
chromosome and you can see that it
matters for some genes so for example
here for all the transcripts or
virtually all the transcripts that are
expressed from allele number one this
particular exon spliced out whereas from
the other allele half of the time to
exxon is retain so it matters which
allele that particular gene product
comes from and with regard what's going
to happen through so the last example in
the transcriptome is in a plant area and
this is a work by roy wang and
co-workers from doreen where's where's
lab at Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory
looking at mays as a Corahn of course is
the largest crop and i didn't have time
to talk about the genome but they also
now is available publicly the latest
version for reference sequence which was
done with peg by sequencing and the ring
mentioned in her talk that previously
the maze project was a 30 million dollar
effort effort by the usda on led by the
usda with many other institutions and
that led to the version 3 and now with
peg pyrosequencing and a estimated cost
reduction of about a factor of a
thousand to about 30,000 dogs which is
done at the time now it would be cheaper
still they have a birdie 4 which is a
much higher contiguity i want to focus
here on the transcriptome part and of
course it's also important for breeding
efforts and for understanding the
different varieties and genotype
phenotype or correlations to get an idea
the transcriptome so different tissues
were collected and subjected to the ice
OSI protocol getting full-length cdna
that was sequence in different size
ranges and there was also a multiplex
strategy involved where the different
tissues from bar-coded so that this can
all be done in one library preparation
and so you can see here that the stark
difference in the availability of
transcripts that was possible in blue
with the previous version three
reference and then with the ISO seek
data so you can see that there's a large
fraction of new transcripts that are in
the range above 2.5 kb or so that are
newly discovered and this is also shown
here in terms of the number of different
isoforms in jeans there is a great
discovery potential these new isoforms
and sometimes neither new genes so in
fact about sixty percent of all the data
where novel isoforms either from known
genes or from novel genes so you can see
here the blue one was already known and
then in red and in in red here
fifty-seven percent on all isoforms of
no means and then three percent were
normalized forms from novel genes and so
this allowed for example Justin was one
example allow a much better
characterization of the functional
diversity of isoforms in 57 mins
transcription factor families and what's
shown here in New our new discovery so
you can see that for all these different
classes of transcription factors there
was a very large component of new
discoveries that was made from the PEC
minor data and so it then allowed though
to get a much more comprehensive and
complete picture about tissue-specific
transcripts and characterizing the
alternative displacement prevents among
the different tissues he found that in
some cases there's quite a lot of
mutually exclusive exons and introns
retention are going on so for example
for these two you can see that the
turquoise bars are for mutually
exclusive exons make it a very large
fraction in the endosperm and the pollen
and here's just one example where we
retain intron that can then of course
are cause a change in the org and can
have different functional consequences
and so this is only possible if you have
a full-length information to understand
this diversity and these were also
validated so and then previously
incorrect gene models have now also been
validated by the ISO seek method so here
are two examples of genes which were
incorrectly annotated in the ref gene
over three so here is the annotation on
the version free reference and so it's
kind of split whereas by looking at the
different issues respect bio here it's
very clear that these are continuous
transcripts and then down here you have
the different tissue distributions and
the different isoforms on the bottom
here is a gene that was completely
missing so you can see there's actually
no line that corresponds to the three
reference and very clearly two different
isoforms where identified in malignant
acyl also it allows them to characterize
really well the novel long non-coding
RNA or link RNA so over 800 novel link
rnase were identified in this particular
work and you can see here's the
breakdown between known and novel link
RNA is giving an insight into the
particular constitution and then here on
the lower right you can see that many of
these linked RNAs are very
tissue-specific so there's very little
overlap in with regard to link rnase
that are in all at present all the
tissues and a large number that are
present and only one a particular tissue
potentially giving insight into the
particular regulation in these tissues
and so speaking of long non-coding RNAs
there is an exciting abstract I hope you
can read this at the upcoming ashg
meeting that's in about two weeks in
Europe this was a group from Barcelona
Spain looking at mapping human long
non-coding RNAs and just to read the
business from the abstract so I'm
looking forward to this presentation
where the application of her generation
along with sequencing in both human and
mouse led to a set of canonical link RNA
slice junctions that increase by two
hundred and fifty percent so more than
double the number of no link rnase in
and these gene models they observed
numerous cases of new exons unified gene
models underlying multiple annotations
and mana make sonic jeans and they also
mapped 132,000 polyadenylation sites
genome-wide so with regard to link rnase
enormous discovery potential as well as
for in the agricultural business so with
that I'd like to conclude by saying that
I hope I've given you an overview that
there's a lot more information that can
be gathered from the genome more than
just snips and of course in that context
the alumina technology is very good at
identifying for the most part for most
regions of the genome a single
nucleotide variation but it largely
ignores the larger structure variation
the phasing of the long-range phasing of
the haplotypes in many cases because of
GC bias there is the need for laborious
gas drilling and then also epigenetics
and de novo assembly and while it is
true that it can be at least in many
cases partially addressed with more made
hair libraries with these synthetically
technologies like duck tail or 10x
genomics gaps can be addressed with pcr
cloning saying or epigenetics with
myself I'd sequencing and an old-world
genome assembly again with cross-linking
methods like cocktail and high seat this
adds a lot of work and certainly gets
you far beyond the so-called
thousand-dollar genome with
is really just a sniff table against a
reference genome and does not give you
all this information and so the point I
was trying to make open a targeted in a
recent lensing and then in the de novo
assembly matter is that smart sequencing
can give you a data set a homogeneous
data set from a single library that can
provide all this particular information
and often the gap filling you know goes
away because there's no need because
there are no gaps in the context rather
than having scaffolds with regard to the
RNA level we find that in the community
that in many cases the researchers
combined short read and long reach
sequencing and so the technologies are
complementary in that regard because
aluminum can still give you a lot of
counts and billions of going to read so
that's very good for counting in you
know we don't have those read numbers
yet but as I mentioned and show a couple
examples to short key technologies occur
if not as good as highlighting and
resolving and capturing the transcript
structure and that's where I so seek is
really good at so being able to use ISO
seek for characterizing the isoforms and
the transcript structure and then
complementing that and with accounting
information is we believe right now the
best way to give you a comprehensive
information on the transcriptome so with
that I just want to make a few remarks
about the sequel system I mean the
effort this this is the instrument that
we announced in October and it gives you
a higher throughput on on the existing
smart technology so the underlying
technology is exactly the same but we've
now increased the capacity of the number
of potential sequencing sites / smart
cell 2 1,000,000 and that relates to
about a six to seven fold increase in
the number of reads that you get per run
it also has an increased footprint and
weight and this about by about a pack of
third respectively and is about half the
cost of the rs2 and so what that means
is that with the larger number of leads
it
uses the time on to the results in the
time to do a study importantly it also
has an inherently scalable throughput
and I want to just make one comment on
this that in contrast to the rs2 where
we really hit a limit in terms of how
many sequencing sites we could have in a
smart cell this is not the case with
sequel so over time it will be possible
on the same Hardware instrumentation to
upgrade the smart cells to giving higher
multiplex to for maybe eight and eight
million zmw s and so on the existing
instrument it will then give you even
more leads and so that means that over
time it will be cost that it will take
to do a human genome de novo assembly
about 50-fold coverages or
recommendation from the current value in
terms of us consumable costs will go
down from about currently about
seventeen thousand dollars over time in
you know two years or so to a price
point where you know it's impossible to
do more and more samples for larger and
larger population-based studies so with
that I would like to conclude but not
before a few acknowledgments and this is
this is actually my first acknowledgment
slide which is to highlight that the use
of the technology by the scientific
community has now led to over a thousand
three hundred papers to well over a
thousand period publications and there
are already about a 350 or so papers
just this year this is an approximate
number because it's actually starting to
get difficult to track the papers
precisely because they're coming out at
such a rapid rate we have between 25 to
30 papers each week that publish on the
use of smart sequencing in the various
different areas or that translates to
one newspaper every on average every six
hours so it's getting hard to keep track
and read them all but you know that's a
really good problem to happen so I show
this life because it is really the
research community and the researchers
and scientists who apply the technology
that we have to thank for we are
extremely grateful for their time and
efforts that they put into the
technology and you know without them you
know this would not be possible it's a
very close collaboration as you noted as
you notice on most of the things that I
talked about we're actually not done by
us but we're done by the scientist in
the community and of course I also want
to thank all the employees at Pacific
Biosciences who work very hard every day
to bring this technology to your
research so with that I'll stop and not
be happy to answer your questions
excellent presentation dr. Carla thanks
for ringing that information to us so
before we get started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll get to as many as we can and the
first question is what is an isoform so
an isoform is an isoform is a particular
form of a gene product so when you have
a gene in the genome it's made up of
usually more than one exxon and so it's
made of exons and introns and in the
process of transcription that makes the
messenger RNA and then is processed by
the ribosome to make a protein the
introns are spliced out and the exons
are stitched together and sometimes you
know an exon is skipped and sometimes an
intron is retained and so with this
modular architecture of the gene you can
end up with different messenger RNAs
that are then processed by the ribosomes
to make different proteins
how does this technology work in the
single cell arena so what we've seen is
it's an emerging emerging area and I
think it's a very exciting area and what
we've seen is that the ability in
particular to resolve full-length
transcripts also for single cells is
very exciting there's a paper from I
would say maybe eight or nine months ago
from the Sanger Institute where they
demonstrate that it is possible to get
information about the genome and the
transcriptome from the same single cell
and in this particular study pacbio
sequencing was used again in this
complementary fashion that I mentioned
at the end of my talk to not only get
counts but also get isoforms different
transcript isoforms for this particular
signal sell these were in cancer cells
and so i think it's a it's a first
demonstration that i know of where the
technology can also be useful for
highlighting differential splicing and
changes in the transcriptome
architecture at the level of single
cells
okay we'll give you another few moments
to send in questions which you can send
them via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window do
you have any more questions okay
transcription you see I think it would
be is transcription affected by
environmental factors so how do you
evaluate or control those factors in
sequencing data so I would say that this
is probably done most prominently
through the study design you know the
sequencing will give you the underlying
information about the genome the
transcriptome and certainly the
environmental factors I think are also
known to affect the epigenome and you
know we didn't have time today to talk
about the unique capability of practice
sequencing to characterize the
methylation status of the DNA as a
process of sequencing but it is
certainly true that if you design your
experiment properly and have you know
cases and controls for the different
environmental factors and the sequencing
can give you information about how these
environmental factors change either the
genome Bobby zebra at Mount Sinai
presented a study at AG BTW that was
recorded so he go to our website and
search for the AG BTW workshop he gave
an example where he irradiated cancer
cells and then with the sequel system
and prepared by sequencing looked at the
changes in the structural break points
at particular genes in particular the RV
one gene and identified new structural
break points and hotspots in break
points through this irradiation of the
cancer cells and so this is a true for
the genome level the transcriptome level
and the epigenome level so with a
properly designed study the sequencing
data can give you very important
information on how that changes on the
genomic constitution of the samples see
what is your opinion about the future
sequence methods that can be used so i
would say that at a high at a general
level in high level we've seen a
transition from sequencing being
sequencing and by that I mean that
before the next generation sequencing
and the third generation sequencing
technologies came along there was really
only one method and that was saying or
sequencing and the research community
had to adapt their particular research
projects to of what Sanger sequencing
could provide this is no longer the case
we now have quite a wide variety of
different sequencing technologies and
they have different strengths and
weaknesses and I was trying to point
those out during my presentation that
the alumina technology is extremely good
for counting because you get lots and
lots of reeds and so it you can count on
whatever is in your sample really well
however their limitations with regard to
read length with regard to bias so that
other applications like the Nobel
assembly like resolving some of these
repeat expansion diseases like resolving
full-length transcripts is not very well
suited with short read sequencing and so
that's where pacaya has a strength and
of course on the flip side you know we
don't have the billions of reeds and so
it's not a very good counting tool so
what that means is that the researchers
now have choices and depending on what
they're trying to achieve and the
questions they're trying to address they
have different choices of the different
sequencing technologies and so you know
our job is to try to help guide the
community to apply the best technology
to the particular needs now long term I
would say that when
long reads become as cheap and plentiful
so when the technologies when the
technology will get scaled up so that it
is possible to get billions of reads
through smart sequencing you know
that'll take some time but I think
fundamentally that will be possible then
I think ultimately people will move on
to longreach sequencing technologies as
the as the default for everything
because then there's really no remaining
advantage the main advantage is
accounting and the low cost right now
and you know there was a series of
Mendel's parte interviews last year
where the moderator throughout Timson
asked five key key opinion leaders five
leading scientists in their particular
area he asked if long waits become as
cheap and as easy to get as long as
short reads would anybody still do
chaudhary than they all said no so I
think long term that's that's where the
field will move and we'll see a
reunification of sequencing technologies
for many areas because we're going to
have a technology that provides the best
possible performance in all areas that
are important for particular research
project the next person says started for
the beginner level questions on an
undergrad trying to expand my knowledge
in the field of genetics so the question
is how r epigenetic modification is
detected by sequencing yeah I apologize
I didn't get to that part and the way
it's detected is through analyzing the
kinetics of polymerization so as the
polymerase moves along in real time and
makes the complementary DNA strand if
that polymerase encounters a methylated
base on the template strand it slows
down temporarily so the methyl group
acts like a little speed bump to the
polymerase and we measure that delay and
then through a statistical t-test we can
determine that that particular basin is
methylated
when do you think sequel will be
optimized to be able to sequence a human
with comparable rs2 metrics so as you
know or as you may be aware we have
continuously improved you know on VRS to
over the years and that will also be the
case for sequel so as I present it in at
the igbt conference some sequel data
we're now getting around five Giga bases
of data with an average read link that's
also on the order of 10,000 basis and
you know and some it also is very sample
dependent and inequality dependent so
the read links might still be a little
bit shorter than it is true now for the
rs2 but you know this will all you know
improve over time and so I want to point
out that these improvements are are
happening on a continuous level and so
on the same hardware over time the
overall throughput will improve and we
expect that to go far beyond the 5k
Cabaye's level and then I mentioned a
force in the talk that it will also be
the opportunity to increase the physical
multiplex so this will this will all
happen in a continuous manner you know
within a couple of months and then more
long term will continues to improve the
technology over the next few years
I would like to once again thank dr.
quarrel up for his presentation do you
have any final comments today thank you
Judy and thanks everyone for attending I
guess my final comment is that please
feel free to contact us if you have
further interest we didn't get a chance
to address all of the questions so I
know that they can be passed along and
I'll be happy to answer those to you
directly and check out our website ww-p
be calm and you can reach out there and
we have delighted to hear from you and
engage in a discussion to see how you
can consider PacBio sequencing for your
research projects thank you very much
thanks to the audience also for their
great participation this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over and to get your credits
click on the seek button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through November 11th
2016 you'll receive an email from us
alerting you when it's available on
demand and posted on lab routes comm
you're welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time